- Hi, Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
And I'm just here to remind everyone
that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization
with a mission of providing
a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere.
And we can only do that work
through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
And if you need any extra
motivation, I will remind you
that there's actually a good
body of scientific research
that one of the top ways
to become a happier person,
which we all want to do,
is to give to others.
And when you give to Khan Academy,
the social return on investment
is really one of the highest
impact philanthropy things
that you can do.
So when you give those dollars,
not only will it help
tens of millions of folks
around the world, but it will
also make you a happier person
as we go through the back
half to 2020 and into 2021.
To make it even better,
every dollar you give will
be matched dollar for dollar
by a matching gift
that we have received from a
very generous philanthropist.
So, as we make our way to the end of 2020,
which has been a tough year,
and more folks are
dependent on Khan Academy
and being able to keep
learning than ever before,
I hope you seriously consider
thinking about how powerful
a donation to Khan Academy
can be, and how happy
that's going to make you.